il est entré en vigueur depuis plus de
deux mois et pourtant le pass sanitaire
anime toujours la colère de certains
français ce samedi 220 manifestations
ont eu lieu dans toute la france ils
étaient quatorze mille cinq cents à
paris ou deux cortèges ont été
particulièrement suivie celui d'abord
initié par florian philippot et les
patriotes
parmi les manifestants des slogans
prônant le retour des libertés la non
vaccination des enfants ou encore la
préférence pour des traitements comme
l'hydroxyte l'euro qui est français
voile usages puisque c'est que se passa
les terres ils voient que ça n'a rien de
sanitaires je sais les politiques de
restriction de liberté que beaucoup de
pays sont en train de s'en débarrasser
est-ce qu'on avait promis le tout
vaccinal et restent sont divertis elle
face à l'inter étant la clé 100 m ça ne
fonctionne pas et on obtiendra la fin de
cette loi de la honte la fin du pass de
là entre autres défiler dans les rues de
la capitale un rassemblement apolitique
organisé par des gilets jaunes tout de
blanc vêtus et mobiliser contre
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants on
soutient évidemment les soignants compte
cette obligation et on dénonce le
l'instauration se passa ni terre on
considère comme étant vraiment le summum
du contrôle des citoyens on est en
pleine dictature sanitaire masqué alors
parce que on instrumentalise la peur de
ce virus en dhr se sert de la peur une
obligation vaccinale qui entre en
vigueur le 15 septembre à partir de
cette date les soignants s'exposeront à
des sanctions
peu importe pour certains c'est la
liberté avant tout aujourd'hui
infirmier et demain je sais pas ce que
je
vais faire parce que je ne compte pas me
faire vacciner et je le fais pour moi
mais pour la population pour les gens
qui sont vaccinées aussi notre famille
ne vaut pas vivre sans bon salaire mais
mon choix est plus important et c'est
une décision commune je vis très mal ça
a été très compliqué pour moi parce que
j'ai fait ce choix mais du jour au
lendemain j'ai beaucoup pleuré parce que
ces douze ans de vie qui s'arrête et
aujourd'hui je sais même pas ce que je
vais faire avec 15000 manifestants de
moins que la semaine précédente
le mouvement semble perdre de l'ampleur
selon un sondage publié lundi dernier
une large majorité des français se
prononcent est d'ailleurs contre la
mobilisation de ces dernières semaines
de quoi confirmer olivier véran dans ses
propos le ministre de la santé affirmait
jeudi que les réticences étaient en
train de tomber des propos à nuancer
puisque les nouvelles vaccination en
france stagne autour de 140 mille
injection de premières doses par jour
toujours selon le ministre de la santé
le pass sanitaire pourrait être lui
prolonger au delà du 15 novembre la
limite fixée par la loi
autorités et services de renseignement
craignent une radicalisation du
mouvement anti passe dès septembre les
organisateurs présent à paris ont en
tout cas invité à de nouveaux
rassemblements dès le 4 septembre
prochain